monsieur gillioz merci des travaux qu'on
direct sur rt france alors la tunique
que représente ce dernier district c'est
évidemment géographiquement très
important parce que c'était sur les sept
districts qui était occupé par les
arméniens
le dernier restant avant la rétrocession
aux azerbaïdjanais c'est chose faite
donc la totalité des districts à l'été
étaient occupés sont intenses
souveraineté azerbaïdjanaise et sont
revenus sur la soul a sous la tutelle 6
puis 10 ou la souveraineté de
l'azerbaïdjan le deuxième point
important c'est qu'évidemment il ya ce
fameux corridor qui vient d'être évoqué
et qui depuis 1994 rôle qu'est le haut
karabagh à l'arménie or ce corridor il
n'est plus totalement opérationnelles ou
pas dans le même sens puisque comme cela
a été rappelé à l'instant il est passé
sous contrôle des forces
azerbaïdjanaises
donc il ya deux solutions désormais où
il ya une négociation pour l'utilisation
de ce corridor de latchine mais sous
contrôle à la fois des azerbaïdjanais et
probablement des russes permettant de
continuer de relier le haut karabagh à
l'arménie ou un autre corridor et créé
de toutes pièces qui permettra de lier
le haut karabagh à l'arménie mais la
question qui se superposent du clip peut
être en réalité la plus compliquée c'est
le statut à venir du haut karabagh
puisque si les azerbaïdjanais ont
légitimement retrouver souveraineté sur
leur territoire qui est illégalement
occupé depuis 1994 la question du haut
karabagh n'a pas été réglée par l'accord
de cessez-le-feu du 9 10 novembre
donc ça laisse place à la négociation
qui probablement se fera évidemment sous
l'égide de la russie
mais pour autant il on peut l'imaginer
assez facilement que d'autres puissances
peut-être le groupe de minsk voudront
aussi avoir leur mot à dire
donc nous allons rentrer désormais dans
une phase de négociation difficile
compliqué mais on est absolument
nécessaire par ailleurs car il vaut
mieux
trouver une solution au statut futur du
haut karabagh par la voie de la
négociation plutôt que par la guerre
mais je pense que les arméniens pour
leur part n'ont guère le choix au vu de
la dégradation du rapport de force en
leur défaveur et probablement tout à
fait souhaitable
les dirigeants azerbaïdjanais seront
ouverts un processus de négociations et
voir de compromis mais cela reste une
page à écrire et il n'en sommes pas
encore tout à fait à cette étape on
appris ce matin ne se sente repose en
observation entre la turquie et la
russie la russie qu'il ya des cas
d'ailleurs déployé à 200 soldats de
maintien de la paix qui a permis cet
accord de cessez-le-feu pourquoi son
rôle est il si important que d'avoir
fuit pas deux sens les deux mille
soldats russes qui ont été déployés dès
le matin du 10 novembre donc les choses
ont été rapidement menés sous la
direction de moscou
et depuis leur force est d'admettre
d'ailleurs que le cessez le feu a été
parfaitement respectée sauf
éventuellement quelques petites
escarmouches mais véritablement
secondaire et que surtout les derniers
districts qui était sous responsabilité
occupation arménienne ont été restitués
comme on l'a dit à la verveine gens donc
cette force de la paix a réellement tenu
son rôle jusqu'à lors l'importance à les
avants allaient par ailleurs politique
c'est à dire que la russie et nul ne
pouvait en douter considère toujours le
caucase et cette partie du caucase comme
son arrière-cour stratégique
il était évident que moscou ne pouvait
pas laisser des forces centrifuges sous
régionale et caucasienne s'emparait de
la situation sans que les dirigeants
russes ne continuent d'avoir un
véritable contrôle sur la situation dont
il est clair que la russie fait partie
des vainqueurs de cette guerre qu'elle
confirme l'importance et l'influencé
qu'elle quelques elkann je cale à cale
possède sur le caucase ce qui est
nouveau c'est l'accord avec la turquie
sur le coca j'entends nous sommes bien
au courant
que sur d'autres théâtres d'opération et
je pense particulièrement à la syrie et
à la libye
les turcs et les russes ont trouvé un
modus vivendi ont trouvé des terrains
d'accord en dépit de leurs divergences
sur le coca c'est sûrement plus
compliqué parce qu'encore une fois la
russie n'est guère disposés à voir la
turquie prend re taux trop d'importance
il me semble plutôt intelligent et de la
part des dirigeants turcs et de la part
des dirigeants russes d'avoir su mettre
en oeuvre ce comité de de surveillance
en quelque sorte qui est à la fois
turquie et russe pour veiller au
maintien du cessez le feu et surtout
veiller à la résolution politique des
différents qui persistent dans la région
donc on voit il part donc s'cusez moi
très rapide en jeu la star mines et
autres phrases 1,6 million la fugue will
temps où on voit là la turquie
s'affirmer comme une puissance qui
compte désormais dans le caucase mais ne
nous leurrons pas le rapport de force
n'est pas une forme de symétrie entre
ankara et moscou
je pense que c'est toujours moscou qui
possède le plus d'influencé et le
maximum d'atouts pour trouver des
solutions politiques dans la région
didier vidéo merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
directeur adjoint de l'institut de
relations internationales et
stratégiques teracent martial